I really miss him a lot huh
[Music]
sometimes
real truth is
I'm not even sure how she could
keep you
[Music]
shut up shut up let me handle this
don't talk to women that way rappully
cowards
[Music]
mail
excuse me do you want mayonnaise on your
BLT
[Music]
I'll make you a BLT to take with you
want to see a movie
uh yeah I would love to all right let's
see what's playing
large cotton chips with soap and vinegar
do you want a pickle deck to go with it
oh
no I'm okay thank you thank you we're
over lacking in the confidence to pump
I'm gonna stand up straight
that's it put your shoulders back
lift your head up face the world
[Music]
thank you
we're scared to face Reggie weren't you
you did it anyway I got this kicked out
of me
can I tell you a secret
[Music]
sure
don't get caught
ghost house has got herself a ghost
ghost house got itself a ghost that's
what I said it was our idea don't get
the kid in trouble
yeah I don't think so whoa what up sis
hello Danny I'm Dr Goodwin but you can
call me Raya
[Music]
inside then
unbelievable oh geez then damn you all
right man
really want a gun
will cost you way more than money no
shut up
here comes that free
hey are you okay
fine bye
we want to buy an ounce of pot we want
to buy an ounce of Pop man
[Music]
five
serve you carbonated urine I think it's
time you get yourself oh my God
[Music]